[موسيقى]
علمانيه اسلام وعبايه ثلاث كلمات عندما
وضعت في جمله واحده كانت كافيه بخلق حاله
من الهستيريا الجماعيه هنا في فرنسا
فبعد النقاب والحجاب حان دور العباءه
منعها في المدارس اثار موجه من ردود
الافعال داخل البلاد وخارجها فلماذا تمنع
السلطات الفرنسيه ارتدائها وهل منعها هو
انعكاس لما يسمى اسلام فوبيا ام دفاع عن
العلمانيه في الدوله ولماذا يصبح التعايش
بين مفهوم العلمانيه واسلام فرنسا فرنسا
اكثر واكثر تعقيدا ماذا عن العباءه كرداء
هل هي رمز ديني بالفعل ام انها مجرد زي
ثقافيه في فلك الممنوع
[موسيقى]
يعرفها معجم المعاني على انها كساء واسع
مشقوق من الامام بلا كمين يلبس فوق الثياب
والنسائيه منها يضيف القاموس الى تعريفها
كلمه فضفض هي العباءه العربيه قطعه النسيج
التي تشغل الراي العامه في فرنسا وتؤرق
كبار سياسيها حتى ايمانويل
ارتداها العرب نساء ورجالا منذ مئات
السنين واحتفوا بها والبسوها معانيه منها
الفخر والوقار والاحتفال ايضا فصارت جزءا
من هويتهم ترجع مصادر تاريخيه ظهور
العباءه الى بلاد الرافدين قبل نحو اربعه
الاف سنه ويروى ان نساء العراق كنا
يلبسنها مزركشه وملونه حتى غزا هولاكو
بلادهن فصرنا يرتدين العباءه السوداء حزنا
وفي عصرنا هذا استخدمتها انظمه متشدده
دينيا كي تفرض على النساء رداءا فضفاضا
على سبيل المثال الى الحصر ايران
والسعوديه حتى وقت قريب وتقول الباحثه
الينور عبد الله دوماتو ان حادثه حصار
متطرفين للحرم المكي عام
1979 تم توظيفها سياسيا من قبل رجال الدين
داخل السلطه السعوديه فصاروا يحذرون
النساء من تقليد الغرب وانكفا المجتمع
السعودي على نفسه على حد تعبيرها بدا فرض
ارتداء النقاب والعباءه مع القوانين
الاخرى التي حدت من حريه النساء
بعد ذلك بسنوات دخلت العباءه الى عالم
الموضه والاناقه ووصلت الى الغرب هنا في
فرنسا لا يوجد توافق على اعتبارها رمزا
دينيا امزيا ثقافيا لكن لمجلس الفرنسيه
للديانه الاسلاميه يؤكد انها ليست رمزا
دينيا اسلاميا حتى وان اعتبرتها بعض
لابساتها كذلك في قرار حظر العباءه تعتمد
السلطات الفرنسيه على قانون يعود لعام
2004 يمنع الرموز الدينيه في المدارس
ينطبق ذلك على الرموز الواضحه كالصليب
المسيحي والقلنسوه اليهوديه والحجاب
الاسلامي لكن في اواخر 2022 اصدرت وزاره
التعليم الفرنسيه قرارا ينص على منع
الازياء التي يهدف ارتدائها بشكل واضح
وبنيه مسبقه الى الدلاله او الافصاح عن
الانتماء الديني او الدعوه اليه لكن من
الذي يعرف النوايا في النفوس وما هو شكل
العباءه المحظوره في مدارس فرنسا اصلا
وكيف نفرق بينها وبين اي ثوب طويل وواسع
كلها اسئله لم تجب عليها السلطات الفرنسيه
بعد
[موسيقى]
اه حلوه
شايفه لك الممنوعه العباءه ومنعها في
فرنسا وابدا هنا في استوديو مع البحث في
الشؤون الاسلاميه ورئيس مؤسسه اسلام فرنسا
غالبا شيخ اهلا بك استاذ غالب وشكرا
لحضورك عفوا سؤالي الاول لك هل تعتبر ان
العباءه هي رداء او رمز ديني ام انها مجرد
زي ثقافي
اعطيك استاذه ميسلون رايك شخص كرجل قبل ان
اتكلم باسم مؤسسه الاسلام في فرنسا التي
تهتم الا بشان الحاضر بشان الحضاري
والتربوي والثقافي ولا تهتم بالشان الديني
البحث ولا بالطقوس الدينيه ولا بالشعائر
الدينيه رايي هو ان
العباءه تعتبر
كسوه او رداء من التقاليد المعمول بها منذ
اربعه الاف سنين مثل ما جاء في تقرير ثمين
وليست لها اي بعد ديني حيث ان حتى في
الاسلام على حسب مفهومي واتكلم امام
الاستاذ محمد ليس هناك
شعار او لباس معين ما كان يدعو له الدين
الاسلامي هو الاحتشام فقط فليست هناك رموز
وليست هناك البسه مقننه مسننه مشروعا لها
طب لماذا اعتبر اليوم الدوله الفرنسيه
انها رمز ديني برايك هذا راجع الى عده
اسباب السبب الاول هو في بعض الاحيان تاتي
بعض التلميذات لانني اتكلم عن التلميذات
ولا اتكلم عن الطالبات تاتي
بحجابهن فمن السهوله بالنسبه اليهن انها
تخلع ما يغطي شعرهن
الخمار او كذا وتبقى
الطويل الذي يسمى العبايه اليوم ففهم من
هذا على اساس انه لباس ديني
نحن نغرق في زوبعه في كاس اذا كان
اللباس دينيا فهناك قانون يحضر اللباس
الديني منذ تقريبا عشرين سنه فان لم يكن
ديني فعلى مدراء المدارس ان يقرروا بما
ناتي به الى المدرسه هناك مقوله في عمليه
اشهار لماكدونالدز اتي مثل ما كنتم
المدرسه ليست ماكدونالدز وهناك مقوله اخرى
فيما يخص
نايت كلوب ما يقال لها
النوادي الليليه
لابد ان يكون مظهركم انيق وجميل هذا اذا
كان في النوادي الليليه فعلى المدارس ان
تطلب لكل مقام ملبس المدارس المدارس لابد
ان ياتوا الطلبه والتلاميذ دبلوماسي جدا
ولكن يعني
اقول لك صراحه صراحه ولكن اليوم لا لا
نستطيع حل هذه المشكله اليوم هناك هذا
النقاش الذي
تريدين ان تعلمين انا مع الحظر او
لنذهب الى امر في النقاش لكي نتمكن من
الاجابه على هذا السؤال يعني بشكل او باخر
دعني ارحب ايضا في الاستوديو بالامين
العام لجمعيات المسلمه السيد محمد حنيش
اهلا بك السيد محمد يعني اليوم
يعني بتكمله هذه الفكره هل توافق مع السيد
غالب على ان هذا الرداء ليس رداء دينيا
ربما بعض التلميذات كما قال يعني يرتدينه
لانهن محجبات فقط وهو ليس له بعد ديني هو
فقط ربما ثقافي توافق
صديقي غالب
الامر انه حتى المجلس الاسلامي
الممثل الجاليه هون في فرنسا
قرار ووضعته القرار في البرنامج بتاعكم
يقول بانه لا يعتبر هو هذا اللباس لباس
اسلامي المشكل المشكل شريحه من المسلمات
والمسلمين هذا القرار لو لم يكن لباسا
اسلاميا
الان فيه محاوله
تنكيل او الاساءه للمسلمات المسلمات تطبق
او لا تطبق الاسلام ولكن المسلمات وغالبيه
البنات لما تشتري هذا اللباس هي لا تشتريه
من المغرب العربي او السعوديه هي تشتريه
من محلات فرنسيه محلات فرنسيه مثل زارا
هذه المحلات لا تسميه عباءه حتى
اللفظارا اوكي لفظ العباءه لا تجديه في
المحل يقول روبلونج مش عباءه هم استعملوا
لكن هناك شكل للعباء اليوم يعني نعرفها
جميعا هناك العباءه السعوديه هناك بقى
الافغانيه يعني هناك انواع من العباءات
التي لها ربما دلاله على اسلام سياسي معين
غالبيه البنات تذهبي الى الثانويه او
المتوسطات غالبيه البنات لهم عباءه
بالوان فاتحه بالوان
جميله ليست العباءه التي نعرفها على
الموضه واهم شيء ان الوزير التعليم بعد
الاسبوع الاول او اليوم الاول صرح بان
المصالح بتاعه احصت 68
مخالفه 68 على كم 12 مليون 12 مليون
تلميذ وتلميذه اذا هذا يدل على شيء بان
الامر لا لا
اقل من الهامشين والكل الامر هي
هوس كما قلت في التقريب تاعكم في هوس حتى
لا نقول لكل ما له علاقه من قريب او بعيد
بالاسلام حتى هذا له علاقه
من جميع الاطراف حتى من قبل بعض الجماعات
يعني التي تعبر باسم الديانه الاسلاميه في
فرنسا يعني هناك ولكن انت تعتبر انه هجوم
على الاسلام هذا طيب تمام ارحب بالكاتبه
ورئيسه الحركه العلمانيه المستقله سامي
العبادي معنا هنا في استوديو ايضا اهلا بك
سيدتي
قلت انك كل رمز يتباهى بدين او ثقافه ما
يجب ان يمنع من مؤسسات الجمهوريه لكن
بطريقه ناعمه ودون الوقوع في الاستفزاز
يعني انت مع منع العباءه ولكن ليس بهذه
الطريقه
هلا شرحت لنا
نشوف اللي نحن امام لباس تقليدي ديني
متبررش
انا حلا جديده للاستفزاز
اذا كان
نعتبر انه لبس ديني يعني ممنوع من من عام
2004 واذا كان نعتبروه لباس تقليدي اللباس
التقليدي اسمه يتطور
تصوروا اليوم الفرنسيس يجيوا للمكاتب ولا
المدارس بيلبسهم التقليدي بتاع القرون
الوسطى صورهم معناها احنا ما عادش في
مدرسه ولينا في حفله تنكريه اذا كان كل
واحد بالشيجي باللباس التقليدي نتاعو
طيب ولكن اليوم للناس ايضا وخاصه للنساء
نحن يعني غالبا ما نقول النساء لديهن
الحريه حريه اللباس لدينا الحق في اختيار
ما يلبسنا وبالتالي هذا يتناقض قليلا يعني
حتى ربما اليوم يمكن ان يختار الشخص او ان
تختار الانسانه لبس تقليدي لماذا ربط هذا
الامر بالدين
وهل تستغربين شعور بعض المسلمين ربما
بانهم مستهدفون لا لا لا
ثم استهداف مبرر
وتسمى مبالغه موجود هذا وهذا موجود صحيح
ماء ولكن
الجاليه الاسلاميه
اقليه منها
تتعامل مع الدوله الفرنسيه العلمانيه اللي
هي العلمانيه خاصه
بفرنسا لانها علمانيه
[موسيقى]
محايده
تتكلم
باسم الانسان الانسان بحث مجرد من كل
عقائده من كل ثقافاته
ولهذا السبب
يمكنها احترام كل الديانات
وبالتالي من حقها ايضا ان تفرض نوع من
اللباس طبعا طبعا طيب دعينا نتعرف على
ضيفنا الرابع والاخير عبر سكايب ارحب
بالمحرر في موقع لاريبوس لايك اولاد
العلماني محمد باسكال حلوت اهلا بك يعني
اليوم يتحدث البعض محمد باسكال انت معروف
بمواقفك العلمانيه المتطرفه الى حد ما
ولكن بعد يتحدث اليوم عن شرطه الملابس في
فرنسا لماذا اصبحت العباءه عبئا على
العلمانيه الفرنسيه اليوم
حقيقه الامر كلنا نعلم
والمسلمون كلهم يعلمون حق العلم ان المشكل
ليس هو اللباس وانما كل الثقافه الاسلاميه
التي
تحرم على المراه المسلمه ان تاخذ وليا من
غير المسلمين
معنى انها عندما المسلمه تبين انها مسلمه
بحجاب او نقاب او
يعني العباءه
قلت لك كيف ما كان لباس
المسلمه ستبقى
مشكل على الدوله
الدوله الفرنسيه لماذا الدوله الفرنسيه
الوطن هنا في فرنسا هو كان كل الوافدين
على فرنسا
يندمجون بالزواج من غير
دينهم لكن المسلم محرم عليها ان تاخذ وليا
من غير
مسلمات كثيرات متزوجات من فرنسيين او من
غير مسلمين يعني هذه انت تعمم اما خرجوا
من الاسلام ولم تعدن مسلمات واما طلبت من
زوجها ان يقطع كلفته وان يصبح مسلما
في الموضوع موضوع العباءه اليوم انت
بالنسبه اليك من المشكل وين
المشكل هو الاسلام
استاذ غالب ما رايك بهذا النوع من الافكار
اليوم
كنا تناقشنا حتى في هذا
البلاتو اعرف الرجل واذا خاطبكم الجاهلون
فقولوا سلاما نعرف ترهاته وخزعبلاته
والهراء الذي رايت هذا
نحن نحن في دوله تحترم الاراء الناس ان
الاسلام لا
يمكن قيم جمه
وريه الفتله العلمانيه الى اي مدى هذا
الراي يعني اذا اردت ان نناقش ممكن ان
نناقشه وكيف نناقشه كنا خذنا في مقالات
ومحاضرات
ايام دراسات في مثل هذا نحن اتباع
عبد الرزاق علي عبد الرازق الذي يرى ان
ليس هناك اي تناقض مع العلمانيه فيما يخص
الدين الاسلامي لان العلمانيه هي تعتبر
مكسب
للعصرنه وللحداثه نحن نرى ان اذا كانت
العلمانيه هي الحياد الديني من طرف الدوله
فهذا نحن نرحب به تماما نحن نرى ان
التسييس الدين هو الغلط هو المشكل نحن نرى
ان تدجين وتوظيف الدين الاسلامي لاغراض
غير روحانيه يعتبر من المشاكل ولهذا ندعو
الى العمل الحضاري التربوي التنويري
الفكري
ونحن ايضا نعلم ان هناك ازمات بالجمع
دون التعميم ولكن الازمه الكبيره هي ازمات
اجتماعيه فكريه نعمل
لتحسينها شيئا فشيء في هذا الزخم الاعلامي
وفي مثل هذا التعميم ايضا الذي لا يساعدنا
وكنت قد سمعت مرتين مع احترامي الكبير
للضيفيكم الكريمين كلمه الجاليه نحن لا
نتكلم عن الجاليه في فرنسا حيث ان الجاليه
من الجلاء نحن نتكلم عن المواطنين نحن
الفرنسيين تكلم عن شريحه من شريء من شرائح
المجتمع الفرنسي وعلى هذه الشريحه ان توفي
بواجباتها كمثل المواطنين ليفوزوا بحقوقهم
كاي مواطن ايضا
ما رايك بهذا النقاش اليوم يعني مع نقاش
العباءه كما كما حصل في في اوقات اخرى من
التاريخ القصير يعني في فرنسا اعيد نقاش
الاسلام وفرنسا وتوائم الاسلام مع
العلمانيه في فرنسا
انا موافقه قوي 100% مع الاستاذ المشكل
ليس هناك مشكل اليوم
طيب لماذا هناك الجدل بين الاسلام وبين
العلمانيه اين هو
المشكل في
الاستعمال فئه معينه من الجاليه او من
مواطنين في فرنسا
فرنسيين او غير فرنسيين
واستعمالهم الاستفزاز ثم استفزاز هم
يستفزون يعني يقول سيد حنيش انهم ضحايا
يعني هم ضحايا هجمه معينه لانهم مسلمون
انت تحكي على العلمانيه الفرنسيه اللي
اللي عندها استراتيجيه
خبيثه ضد الاسلام والمسلمين لا انا اقول
اكرر هو قال هو عكس سمى بوت
اسلاميه
السياسيه او غير سياسيه اللي عندها
استراتيجيه الخوف من التطرف الديني هذا ما
تقول السيده ساميه اليوم ربما الدوله
الفرنسيه بقيمها وبعلمانياتها ربما تخاف
من التطرف الديني ومنع العباءه هو جزء من
محاربه هذا التطرف الا تراه كذلك سيد حنيش
انا لا ارى ذلك لان الان نتكلم مع من مع
اطفال مراهقين اكبر في ثانوي اكبر بنت
عندها 17 سنه الاغلبيه 13
سنه تفكر ان تهدد الدوله الفرنسيه تظنين
ان اداه في ايدي
المسلمين
في الاسلام السياسي هذا هراء كله هراء انا
اخالف السيد غالب لما قال بان السيد
الحدود ان هذه خزعبلات هذه ليست خزعبلات
كلامه صواب ما قال ما قاله ان المشكله هي
الاسلام انه هو يفكر في هذا والمشكله انه
ليس وحيدا الافكار هذه الان تسللت في
الفساد كانت بعض الافراد مثل السيد وهذا
ليعيش فقط الا في المواقع التواصل
افكار حتى لو كانت افكار شاده نحترمها
المشكله الان ان اصحاب السياسه واصحاب
السياسه من الطراز الاول اصبحوا يميلون
الى هذه الافكار ولكن مقتنعه لكن
المتطرف ولكن اليوم هناك ايضا يعني
استطلاعات راي في فرنسا المواطنين
الفرنسيين 81% من المواطنين الفرنسيين مع
قرار منع العبايات في العبايات في المدارس
لا يمكن ان تقول عن كل المواطنين المساكين
يعني اليوم الاستطلاعات تريد ممكن
تستعملينها كما تريدين المجتمع الفرنسي لم
يطالب ولا مره بمنع العباءه مسكين المجتمع
الفرنسي له مشاكل كبيره ولم نتحدث لما
تحرك المجتمع الفرنسي
يعني كانوا منزعجين ولا مدراء المدارس
عباره عن انزعاج من هذا النمط من اللباس
خلق مشاكل كثيره
هناك ايضا ارتفاع القليله انزعاج في عدم
الامكانيات
ولكن كل هذه الانزعاجات وضعوها جانبا
واخذوا هذه النقطه التي لا تمثل في
اولويات
هناك ايضا استطلاعات اخرى تقول انه نسبه
يعني ارتكابات او الانتهاكات بحق كل ما هو
علماني في فرنسا ارتفعت بشكل كبير في
الاوساط المدرسيه ما بين عام 2021 وعام
2023 انا قلت اعطيتك رقم لان هذا كل هذا
كلام شعري وكلام
الوزير ارقام من الوزاره التعليم قالت بان
فيه 68 حاله عباءه وزاره التعليم قالت في
هذه في السنه الماضيه كان فيه 850 الف
تحرش على الطلبه لكن لماذا
58 الف فيه اولويات مقلوبه الاولويات
مقلوبه محمد باسكال اولويات مقلوبه اليوم
هذا النقاش بالنسبه للسيد حنيش تفضل
قلت لكم ان المشكل هو الاسلام بكل تجلياته
لانه اولا وقبل كل شيء ثقافه لا تمت الى
الاختلاط والامتزاج مع الاخرين
اليوم يعني مصر منعت النقاب في المدارس
السعوديه منعت العباءه في اماكن
الامتحانات يعني وهو هؤلاء مسلمين
لكن ولا مسلم واحد وغالب بن الشيخ من
بينهم قال
الولاء والبراء صوره في الاسلام تمنع
المسلمين
مندماج في دول غير مسلمه ومع المسلمين
لو سمحت يعني خلينا نبقى اليوم يقول سيد
محمد حنيش في فرنسا اولويات اخرى خاصه في
قطاع التعليم قطاع التعليم يفتقر الى
المال يفتقر الى الاساتذه لماذا نركز على
العباءه عوض فتح هذا النوع من النقاشات
هذا سؤال لك تفضل
العباءه ليست سوى رداء ليغطي على اعيننا
المشكله الحقيقيه التي هي جسد المراه عوره
وجسد المراه المسلمه مخصص للمسلم
وهذا هو ما يعنيه كل هذا الامر مع
العلمانيه يعني ليس قلت لك اساسا
يتناقض مع مفهوم
الامه الفرنسيه التي ليست امه دينيه وانما
من اتى اليها يندمج وينصهر مع الاخرين
دعنا نشاهد معا
دعنا نشاهد معا شهاده يعني تلميذتين من من
احدى الثانويات في فرنسا
ترتديان عاده العباءه ومنعت من ذلك كيف
عاشت هذه التجربه او هذا المنع
نستمع معا
ارتدي العباءه لانني اشعر بالراحه فيها
انه لباس فضفاض وهو كغيره من الملابس في
اليوم الاول من بدايه العام الدراسي عندما
وصلت وجدت عناصر من الشرطه امام مدرسه
الثانويه لم افهم سبب وجودهم في البدايه
لكن في الواقع كانوا هناك للتحقق مما اذا
كان الجميع يحترم القانون الجديد قلت
لنفسي انه امر غير طبيعي فان اردنا المجيء
بالعباءه مثلا ماذا سيفعلون سياخذوننا الى
السجن منذ اقرار قانون منع ارتداء العباءه
اشعر بتوتر شديد عندما اذهب الى المدرسه
اشعر انه ينظر الينا وكاننا خطر على الرغم
من اننا مثل جميع البشر وهذا امر مؤسف جدا
في الصباح تساءلت ان كانوا سيقبلون دخولي
بثوبي على رغم من انه ليس عباءه على
الاطلاق وقد اخذت ملابس احتياطيه في
حقيبته لاني لا اريد ان اطرد الى المنزل
انهم يجبروننا على ارتداء الملابس التي
يريدونها اجد ان قانون العباءه غير منطقي
فاما يطبق على الجميع او لا يطبقوا على
الاطلاق لانه ليس من العدل ان يفرض فقط
على المسلمين
انا واجهت هذه المشكله ايضا لم يسمح لي
بالدخول الى المدرسه لانني كنت ارتدي ستره
طويله وهذا امر غير طبيعي فالمدرسه للجميع
يجب الا نحكم على قطعه لباس كل شخص يرتدي
ما يريد نحن في فرنسا
منعت ايضا من الذهاب الى رحله مدرسيه وهذا
بسبب حجاب امر لم افهمه حتى الان خاصه
كانت خارجه نطاق المدرسه
انهم يربطون دائما بين اصولنا وديننا
اخبرنا بعض موظفي مدرسه الثانويه انه تم
وضعه قائمه باسماء كل الطالبات المسلمات
المحجبات
وكانها وصمه عار هذا تنميط
هذا الموضوع يجب ان لا يكون اصلا محطا
نقاش ولا ينبغي لاحد ان يتدخل بخيارات
الاخرين لانها لا تزعج لقد سالنا رفاقنا
من ديانات اخرى وبصراحه لا احد منهم ينزعج
من رؤيه العباءه في المدرسه
سمعت معنا الى الى تلميذات اليوم هناك خوف
من التنميط هل تعتبر ان التنميط المسلمه
قد يكون نتيجه لهذا المنع اليوم في فرنسا
هذا ممكن وان سمحتي لي استاذه ميسلون اريد
ان ارجع تحت الى ما سبق
عملا بمقوله رحم الله امرا اهدى لي خطائه
فانا مستعد لاسحب كلمه خزعبلات ولكن اريد
ان اقول ان هذا راجع الى الهلوسه والى
الهراء والى الهستيريه الجماعيه راجعه الى
الانتصار الفكري الايديولوجي لليمين
المتطرف والغريب في الامر ان العبد الفقير
الذي ينظم ملتقيات حول حريه التعبير وحريه
الانفتاح وحريه الراي وحريه التدين هو
الذي يتهم على اساس انه يدافع على مبدا
الولاء والبراء ولست ادري يعني هذه من
الغرائب الامور نجد انفسنا بين المطرقه
والسندان فنال اريد ان اجيب عن هذا فتاه
واجيب عليه
بما انك تط مساله صعود اليمين متطرف ليس
فقط في فرنسا في كل العالم اليوم نقاش مهم
مساله القيم يعني اليوم الديانه الاسلاميه
بكل ما تحمله من قيمه واسلوب حياته واسلوب
عايش
نقاش هل يمكن ان تستمر
بكل قيمها في ظل قيم مثل القيم التي
تحملها الدوله الفرنسيه ومنها العلمانيه
الى هناك نقطه النقطه الاولى نقطه مساله
القيم القيم الاسلاميه ليست وحيده للاسلام
بل هي للعائله الابراهيميه اليهوديه
والمسيحيه والاسلام اذا كان حب الاخر
الانفتاح
الاخاء المساواه الرفق بالناس هذه كلها
حتى الحفاظ على بعض المبادئ والتعاليم
داخل العائله وكل شيء اما فيما يخص تعاليم
الجمهوريه وقيم الجمهوريه نحن نعلم اننا
نعيش في دوله علمانيه تفصل ما بين الدين
والدوله وان المج تمع الفرنسي ليست له
مرجعيه دينيه بل هو
مجتمع التعليمي
اليوم انه مستهدفين يعني السيد حنيش قال
انه مستهدفين ليش
لعده مقاربات هناك هذه المعضله فيها
مقاربه اجتماعيه سياسيه سيكولوجيه لاهوتيه
ثقافيه اعلاميه كل هذه المقاربات تجعل ان
هناك انكماش حول قضايا الهويه اكيد ان
هناك بغضاء وشحناء
وكراهيه تستهدف
المسلمين لان من قبل من قبل الذين يصور
لهم
وتصاغ لهم فكره ان العنصر الاسلامي دخيل
على المجتمع الفرنسي وايضا هناك خلط ما
بين مغاربي او عربي او افريقي مع كونه انه
من اصول المهاجره والاسلام
وقيم الجمهوريه الفرنسيه هذا الخلط دون
التريث ودون فهمي بكل
ما يجب من بروده اعصاب جعل غير المسلمين
يرون المسلمين على انهم من العناصر
الدخيله لمجتمع وهناك ذوي الفكر الهش وحتى
العاطفه يرون انهم دائما في
في تعميم
كانهم دائما ضحايا هذه فكره الضحايا
توافقين ست ساميه على هذا التحليل لديك
ربما
انا حبيت
نقول اللي كنقولوا لي الاسلام جعل لكل
زمان ومكان مش معناها الاسلامي يطبق اليوم
كما كان يطبق في القرن الثامن والتاسع
والعاشر
كيقولوا للاسلام
لكل زمان ومكان بالعكس نقولو اللي هو عنده
قدره على التكيف في كل الاماكن وفي كل
الازمنه
ولذلك عندك الاسلام في افغانستان مش
الاسلام في ايران مش الاسلام في السعوديه
مش الاسلام في افريقيا مش الاسلام في في
تونس
اذا لماذا اوروبا وفرنسا لا
اعطي وجهه وجه اخر
للاسلام يتوافق مع المبادئ متاحه
العلمانيه وهذا المنع هو جزء من اعطاء هذا
الوجه بالنسبه اليك
منع العاب يعني منع العباءه وغيرها من
الرموز
بالتاكيد
يعني انت تدعين ربما الى اسلام تنويري او
اصلاح اسلام الليبرالي ليبرالي اوكي كما
ان هناك يهوديه ليبراليه
ومسيحيه ليبراليه يجب ان يكون اسلام
ليبرالي ولقد بدا في بعض البلدان العربيه
وفرنسا مثلا مع مدام كان بهلول
وليس هناك حجاب وليس هناك عباءه ولكن هناك
الاسلام الحقيقي
يعني ان الحل ربما يكون بان يلبس الاسلام
هنا في فرنسا الثوب الفرنسي وليس الثوب
تقريبا البنات هون في فرنسا مثلا حتى في
الحجاب لو ترين الحجاب فرنسا تذهبي الى
بلاد الخليج او بلاد المغرب العربي ليس
نفس الحجاب
هذه اذواق انا ارى ان الحجاب في فرنسا له
ذوق شويه موت شويه اوروبي شويه جميل
ولكن مش مثل المغرب العربي نقطه مهمه كتير
غالبا الشيخ اعرفهم جيدا واتابعه هو
تقريبا من القلائل الناس لنفتخر بهم هو
صوت نفتخر به ومعتدل في فرنسا شوف الاخر
ضيف الكريم
وصفه بانه صاحب الولاء والبراء هنا في
فرنسا شيطنه لكل صوت المسلمين يفتخرون به
وحتى هو معتدل رجل معتدل ولكن هو شيطان ما
بالك بالاخرين بالائمه
ان شاء الله هنا في فرنسا سنحتضن الالعاب
الاولمبيه شيء جميل جدا وكل العالم سينظر
الينا في الالعاب الاولى الالعاب
الاولمبيه
نحن في صلب النقاش العالم الاولمبيه
المؤسسه تسم النساء بارتداء الحجاب
الرياضيات فرنسا تمنعه فرنسا تمنعه
شيء خارج للعاده محمد بعض الرياضيات
الفرنسيه تريدنا ان تشارك في باسم فرنسا
ولكن فرنسا قالت اذا تشاركين
الحل ان الان قال كلمه ممتازه الان هذا
علينا ان نتقبله ونفهمه فشلنا وخسرنا فيه
معركه خسرناها هي معركه الافكار الان كل
الكلام حذاري من اليمين متطرف ان يصل
الحكم اليمين المتطرف الان لم يصل ممكن
يصل ولكن افكاره وصلت هذه الافكار اليمين
المتطرف وصلت الى الحكم ووصلت الى الصحافه
واصحاب
السياسي مش مش محمد باسكال حلوت اليوم يوم
يعني بعدها بعد هذا النقاش قد يفهم انه
انت اليوم تقدم اليمين المتطرف في فرنسا
وليس راي العلمانيه لان العلمانيين وافتخر
لانه نجح حلوت نجحت وافتخر
تفتخر تفتخر براي يريد ان يلغي ربما
مجموعه من الناس او اسلاما بكل بساطه بكل
بساطه ليست هناك سوى تونس التي
تخلت عن الولاء للمسلمه ليس هناك سوى تونس
التي تخلت عن الولاء للمسلمه والسيد انا
لم اتهم
غالب بن الشيخ انه صاحب الولاء والبراء
كداعش وانما لانه مسلم ولم يقل ان سوره
الولاء والبراء حرام حرام علينا ان يقول
او ان يقول يا سيد محمد يعني اليوم النقاش
النقاش اليوم
حول حول مجموعه كبيره شريحه كبيره من
المواطنات والمواطنين الفرنسيين الذين
يشعرون اليوم انه يصوب اليهم واليهن
بالاصبع لانهن او لانهم مسلمين
وهذا يعني تمييز فعليا في القانون الدولي
هذا تمييز في قانون في الحقوق الانسان هذا
التمييز كيف تجيب على هذا الراي
المسلمه تميز نفسها من بين المواطنين
الفرنسيين لان
رحمها لم يعد بوتقه
لماذا كيف تميز نفسها المسلمه في فرنسا
المسلمه لا تتزوج سواب المسلم
وطالما وطالما اصبح هذا طالما هذا القانون
في القران فليس صالحا لكل دوله وليس صالحا
لكل مكان وزمان خلافا الحجه التي تقدمها
اليوم لتقول ان المسلمين لا يمكنهم ان
يكونوا جزءا من المجتمع الفرنسي هو مساله
زواج المسلمه نعم طالب لغير المسلم
الحجه الوحيده محمد باسكال جسد المراه
المسلمه حرام وعوره طالما امن المسلمون ان
جسد المراه عوره فمعنى انهم يستحوثون على
المراه
الاجساد
جسد المراه المسلمه عوره صوت المراه عوره
كمان موافقه المراه عوره يعني كل ما هو
حول المراه
يقلق
يسبب قلق لماذا ويسبب خوف لمذهب الخوف من
المراه المجاهد الاكبر الحبيب بورقيبه
منع الحجاب في 81
في المدارس وفي المؤسسات التي تمثل
جمهوريه التونسيه
فرنسا قامت بنفس الشيء اكثر من 20 سنه بعد
بورقيبه
وانا موافقه
100% مع الدوله العلمانيه الفرنسيه
لانها سوف تساعد هذه الفتيات القاصرات
المراهقات على
قبل ان نختم يعني اريد ان اختم بفكره
استاذ غالب هناك خطر في كل هذا النقاش على
فرنسا بالنسبه اليك
هناك تشنجات فكريه وقد راينا حتى
اعطيت لنا وقت متسعا من الوقت ولكن هو غير
كافي
لحل كل هذه
نرى هناك من يعمم حول بناءات انسانيه
فكريه ويجعلها من صميم القران ومن جوهر
الدين الاسلامي الذي هو منتشر من
اندونيسيا الى السورينام عبر وكان من
القبيله الا حتى الى الدوله المدينه
الدوله مثل سنغافوره التي تتراسها امراه
ونحن لن نتغنى بالمجد التليد بل نرى ايضا
ان هناك مشاكل النقطه الثانيه نحن نعاني
ايضا من من الانغلاق ومن فكر ظلمي ان
تتكلم عن المسلمين اتكلم عن المسلمين
وتكون لقد انتهى الوقت
لنفتح على فكره ربما نناقشها في حلقه
ثانيه فرنسا اليوم
امام شرخ اجتماعي بسبب مساله الاسلام ام
لا نحن على حافه هواء هويه سواء اننا ان
الحكمه تسود وسوف نذهب الى ما هو احسن
المشاكل جمه اجتماعيه وسياسيه وحتى مناخيه
والا نبقى فيما يخص مثل هذا الحديث العقلي
نقاش عقيم اليوم للاسف الشديد اعت
ذر حاولنا حاولنا انه الوقت لدينا نشره
اخبار لان النقاش له نتركه لك ولك حريه
التفكير وحريه الاختيار الى اللقاء في
حلقات جديده على شاشه واثير اذاعه تحياتي
[موسيقى]